all right what the Kevin Barrett is
saying the ranking but I remember
certainly on the House Ways and Means
Committee the guy who came up with the
tax cuts that we got is this notion that
we get you know
heavy heavy dependency from China on on
the drugs and related supplies that we
really depend on seventy percent of them
are coming from that neck of the woods
so the administration should kicking
around the idea at least Larry Kudlow
raised it that maybe we entice those
companies back for that region cut their
tax rates in half they're already pretty
low right now to incentivize them back
to our chores let's get the read on all
this with labor secretary Eugene Scalia
joins us out of Washington DC secretary
very good to have you is that being
given serious consideration sir I think
that yes our dependency on other nations
particularly China is something that is
getting a careful look as we examine
what our economic future is going to
look like as we pull out of this
coronavirus pandemic and earlier this
week Neil as you know the president took
action to prevent federal retiree funds
from being invested in Chinese companies
including Chinese munitions
manufacturers that was not in our
national security interest it wasn't in
the interest of those retirees some of
whom were military but because of some
risks that are presented by these
Chinese companies that's just one
example of a reappraisal that I think
will happen about our dependence on
other countries particularly China you
know the reaction to cutting the
corporate tax rate already pretty low in
half for some of these companies I don't
know how you sort that out secretary for
those companies that are gonna look over
and see well why is their rate half what
my Bloods were the American people's
reaction when a lot of them are
clamoring for more these $1200 checks do
you have any position on either my
position is that generally we are
reopening is it as you just emphasized a
moment ago it's been an extraordinarily
difficult time for the American people
so many lives lost so many families
disrupted and and and so many people out
of work but we're now pulling out of
that
and we need to take a look at additional
measures to sustain American
manufacturing that has been an emphasis
of this president from the day he began
running it was NAFTA more than anything
else that prompted the President to run
US MCA has been one of his great
achievements and that was about saving
American manufacturing saving American
jobs and I think continued focus on that
makes sense in terms of other measures
let's see what we need Congress the
president acted so quickly in March
there's been a lot of stimulus in there
and the focus now from my perspective is
on the reopening you're the labor
secretary United States you're more for
you than anyone with the job losses that
have piled up and those filing for
unemployment planes secretary where
we're now with the last eight weeks 36
and a half million Americans have filed
for such benefits fears that the
unemployment rate could could jump up to
20% even test the the old-time highs of
close to 25 percent during the Great
Depression what do you think of how how
bad this gets let me take issue with one
phrase that you've used meal which is
job losses there are tens of millions of
Americans that have been put out of work
and it's a great hardship for them but
many of those jobs are not lost yet and
I've seen three different surveys over
the last week showing that about 90% of
Americans on unemployment think it's
temporary think they're going back to
those jobs what we want to do now is get
them back there safely
the longer the reopening takes I think
the harder that gets but this is a
really unusual economic circumstance
we're in and did not result from
problems the underlying fundamentals as
for example the Great Depression so I
think analogies there are of limited
value what we have is a sailfin to give
you a Klausner let me give you a current
one if you don't if you don't mind sir
and that is what's happening now with
the tensions between ourselves and the
Chinese and the president is obviously
very concerned that they were not being
level with him when talking about the
kernel virus obviously talked about you
know the shielding or investments in
Chinese related firms I get that but it
seems to me and you were close to read
of this and I'll ever be
that that China deal that trade deal is
all but up in smoke right now do you
have any any concern that the jobs and
the bang for the buck we were hoping to
get from a trade deal because we trusted
the Chinese would make good on those
commitments now it's in doubt because we
already know they they weren't on the
up-and-up about this virus well we will
need them to abide by their commitments
obviously and I think that assumes
greater importance not less because of
other misgivings that they've caused
from how they handled the virus but I
think as we look forward again millions
of Americans out of work what we're
focused on is making that temporary buy
safely reopening the economy right now
putting people back to work and as we
reopen across the country we're already
seeing that this has been so fluid Neal
and and we're finally seeing people
getting back to work it's a good sign
sir thank you very much it's always good
chatting with you yeah appreciated
secretary of the United States